[Music]
hello everyone good evening welcome to
Sandwich S Club and our regular Thursday
nights with the viewers Choice and the
Romantic era games I'm here with you my
last of three one a Thursday night
lecture following next week will be
Grand Master Robert honkofsky right for
that weapon okay for three weeks so you
can submit your games to info at st.
Louis chess club dot org and he will he
will analyze your games the ones that he
finds that after that they have the ones
that they have benefits for everyone
that they can everybody can learn from
them they have higher education higher
education educational value than others
and following that I think that would be
Grand Master it would it will be
followed by with Grand Master Alec
Slenderman so both very very
knowledgeable very very strong
grandmasters from whom you can learn a
lot another point I want to make about
the viewers choice night is that if if
you want I don't want to answer any any
game you send as long as you keep some
information about yourself and what's
your name is like this one is a very
interesting and not only me that other
teams are taught this one is already
very interesting this game but I don't
know who is the player with black pieces
so he says hey I just watched one of
Eric Rosen's lectures on your channel
and felt obliged to show you this game I
played I am NOT a very strong player
14-hundred but I am working to become
stronger sounds good
both your channel and Eric's have helped
me to get where I am today and he's sure
to help and are short to help me get
even further so hope this game helps
okay I picked the game it's a very
interesting game but we don't know whom
we are talking to so mister
DeMuth I know it's not him he's white
Bishop to Bishop to c4 all right so any
questions before I start anything why so
you also can submit your games for
tonight oh well who is he and everyone
online so we can go over the games it's
not about you want or you lost or there
are questions about you or there is what
you consider as ridiculous blunders you
can learn from anything as long as there
is something critical in the game so I
chose this game because it's a Sicilian
and it's an interesting Sicilian so he
4590 f 3e 64 64 this is referred to as
the open Sicilian a6 and Bishop e3 well
who plays this front white side I played
I mean I played with those who is it who
is an e4 player here okay so have you
faced oops sorry
how you face this position before what
face this position before
I'm not sure what exactly
I see okay anybody else has have seen
his position before you play that but
that's what that's what you play okay
we should be 3-0 there are many other
choices here there is there's Knight c3
as well
there's also c4 even move
but this spawn a little bit I'm not sure
so when anybody tells us about this
position if they have played before no
no as play okay so this move what what
can be White's plan I mean he just
develops a piece right so black plays
Knight f6 we can play if I write because
25 yes so I have to defend this pawn and
white plays f3 so now I see what white
wants to do white wants to go for the
English attack with Knight c3 Queen d2
and long castle and then G 45 there's a
there's a problem here that idea works
in this more water
but now in this position with the Queen
and c7 the move d5 doesn't have so much
power does it so that's why white setup
doesn't work in here and falls apart so
let's have a look at them so f3 already
a mistake Bishop e3 may be inaccurate
I'm not sure about its inaccuracy but
already for example after Knight f6 if
you go Bishop d3 for example you can
manipulate ePHI followed by d5 right
Knight B 335 and blacks problems are
more or less all right
are we good any questions Ben no
questions okay
all right any comments about the
position that I can address maybe
nothing all right
I hope they're good comments all right
Queen c7 alright this one I'm not sure
again Queen c7 because it gives the
chance to water play the most c4 and why
it has what is called Marazzi bind well
what sort of it emergency bond what's
the plan when you have one out see like
I said okay well it can happen in from
d4 openings as well because when you
Plex I see if I went takes 94 yeah you
that's the first thing and then well
Sciences majors but now this gives you
extra space that's the bind is that you
are not occupying center you are
controlling the center and the control
comes from the central pawn on d4 and
this the side pawn the close to center
pawn on c4 so white has extra space on
the Queen side so he can start expanding
and with this setup if the black spawn
is other way if the bishop with the pawn
is okay suppose here if this point was
here then you had to try to use this d5
square but now the five square is not
possible to use so while she goes with
Knight c3 push every to castle I'm just
making some some random losses not
random you just these are regular moves
and blacks plan is to play this move
rook e8 and then when you were the
bishop here white in return will play
King 2h what I use a different color
this one bishop you g want to reinforce
they have to watch the because blacks
eventual plan is to play d5 and white
has to prepare to play against it and
then white also wants to expand on this
side what White has to be careful is
that once the pressure gets to see 75 if
the bishop is on gg for this f4 score
become critical because the bishop can
jump there - if f4 so you have to be
careful by placing the rook on see why
you're always prone to this skewer right
you gotta watch that
so did I change the color for this you
kind of will understand it questions
doesn't make sense oh wow that's I'm
flattered just thank you saying that
that's very kind so well by the way Joe
send your games to San Luis just Club
info at st. Louis chess club that will
work and I'm sure they will look at your
games so let's go back to the game so
here Queen c7 is bad why because it
gives a chance so what are we supposed
to do instead or should have blocked on
d5 yes immediately
and if I go to five
ah what is in 97f for your upper tempo
which is a six your upper tempo compared
to French defense which is a six which
is not that valuable this is valuable to
some extent would be fine
but it's not so much maybe you could
have start with a movie 5 and then d5
Knight goes b3 or the 95 doesn't matter
than 25 and now this a 6 part becomes
valuable because it controls this check
now d5 is a strong are we good everybody
following oh I didn't mean that
are we good so if I was probably the
strongest oh let's check I I decided I
look at this these games with my own
intuition not with that with the engine
so you see that how we can understand it
he wants to give it to give a try to see
what the engine says just just this this
pointless instance or is the where is
the engine energy
where is the engine I don't say that
it's one of these places is hard okay I
have keep it sir
all right I mean just just checking Wow
Wow somebody has analyzed this position
1,700 people have analyzed this position
and id5 is a better move so if I was
somehow is not that great it's not that
bad II there okay D if I was better than
although this much what does white wants
play next d5e 590 ft 7f 4 right yeah I
mean I think maybe knight c6 or it's
just Queen b6 yeah but then there's c3
you cannot take this point your queen
will be trapped yeah it's very very cool
oh it's getting a very very complex
position here well anyways no you see it
says it says it's unclear anyways well
let's leave it there I don't want to go
to so deep about this one
so Queen c7 not a good move then we give
it a question mark so in the empty five
or if I was giving a good position to
black already Bishop d3 is it a good
move now he's not fighting for d5 you
have to understand that the 5 is an
important move black plays before this
is a good move
he 5 a good move
but but I can maybe do this a for after
before I can castle and if he goes the
cipa should be seven I can go see four
yeah
and after takes takes d5 not block is
way behind in development so d5 doesn't
work other than that now this majority
can become very dangerous right away two
against one and White has a great great
initiative here if if black doesn't take
then de-spawn becomes a weakness because
this point is better to be better to be
here than here right because it's not
closer to watch camp that you can
capture it you can you can kind of
quarantine and capture it right I can go
a 5 and then detach the pawn from its
from its root right so so b5 again not a
good move but then finally someone
decides that ok I gotta take some
serious measures ok here how do you take
back on e3 these moose are they're all
sort of waste of time and that this is a
mistake
why because I can if I take with a queen
black must take because g7 is hanging
black must take on e3 and I look at this
why is it with a pawn structure because
with the Queen's off the board the
dynamic the dynamics fizzle that fizzled
out are already right there's no nothing
but now it's all about the structure
right now
and now the pollen d7 is backward it
takes a long time a lot of work to play
the move d5 and even d5 it doesn't have
the same power because the bloom f3
undermines White's King but without the
presence of the Queen and the dark
square Bishop what are you supposed to
get out of it absolutely nothing so in
this moment for example if black plays
the move castle which is not a good move
what can y do now those pawns being
pushed our targets the a6 mb5 if you
know if you ask me what would you wish
to what would you wish to do as black
let's just make this move move it maybe
it's a better move
I wish I could put this pump back to be
six or put his pump back to be six ob6
probably not but I would have done this
if you tell give me to move so I would
go I could go a four here and after take
his force right because now I have to
attack us on b5 right does it make sense
after take stakes not have it I have a
clear target here and I have a open
square for my Knights
and I can push these pawns as far as I
can because I have this space to do so
are we good this position in terms of
your evaluation it's probably + / - for
my level probably at constants level is
winning already any comments or
questions been any questions you have
maybe then then doesn't have a question
it never asks a question ever alright
knight c6 tonight III is a mistake so
this this quaint trade is very important
how do we how should we have known about
it looking at the pawn structure every
move every part move counts and a lot of
time when you want to do a queen trade
the first thing you have to look at are
two things it's my king safe after the
Queen trade am i three things what is
the material balance and the third thing
is the pawn structure number one King
safety number two material number three
pawn structure when you want to trade
the Queen's so 93 96 Queen e2
you want to move the Queen this move
freeze the Square D - for the night
sounds good but what about this pin
never stay in a pin Queen f2 or even you
could play them of king each one both
moves are equally good so Queen e2
Bishop d7 before ah is it a good enough
guys no it can't be you want to play a
move you want play for but first thing
first look at the position first address
the first the very first problem you
have what's your first problem
King gets one
okay never stay in the pain
any questions Ben is laughing he's
having a good time online p4 I bet I
cannot work like this year just left me
she's sitting there laughing what's
what's that people are nice all right
Castle ninety-two and now finally comes
the move d5 now is better clearly black
right again what's up okay finally the
move comes King catch one alright nice
we're good
97 unnecessary black should have gone
forward probably but I'll do this this
move 95 maybe alright 97 that's not a
bad move 93 losses upon so very
important lesson for everyone every move
chick chick the material balance and
when there is a conflict in the center
anywhere there is a conflict can't you
see how does this so primitive but it is
it is important like if you want to
teach if you want to be a good coach the
the first 200 trainings to to now it
should be showed in 200 positions that
kids have to do the best capture and not
less than 200 positions the best capture
so here there are three attackers and
the night leaves the defense so might be
3e takes e4 F takes e4 964 takes takes
Knight c5 and Bishop c6 now let's
evaluate the position please have a pawn
black a central pawn four against two
what's the strongest minor piece on the
board Bishop on c6 yes so what could be
the easiest plan for black to try to get
to convert his huge advantage into a
winning one
I give everyone a couple of minutes
everyone online also please take your
time in this one Ben is not here to take
your words moves right now but I'm sure
he'll be back by then just ruining
band's reputation you know plan not
tactic plan
then come on people are waiting for you
nothing take your time
you got some suggestions okay you guys
have one more minute
again a plan where the pieces are going
for black because we're not computer
we're not playing move by move we need
to have a base can be the main plan
where our pieces are going the main
hassle is what the night on c5 right
that's what we have to deal with right
all right time up so answers tonight is
on c5 how do you get there the night is
on c5 this Knight is sitting there
strong and powerful he's not going
anywhere then anybody else what the you
don't need to go after anything further
you have a you have a serious majority
in the center and the King size right if
you just can make mobilize that majority
that should be winning that should be
enough to win a game right if you can go
F 5 F 4 F or and then you go F 3 this
black is white black is about to
checkmate the King right if you can open
up that diagonal right is that correct
that's a lot of work isn't it so for
example here why play them of Queen c2
then any any quite any comments online
no comments
ah-1 day followed by what unclear
another plan was alright not this is
bishop on c4 doesn't do anything doesn't
do it the bishop should you stay on the
diagonal so the winning plan okay I look
at this position for two minutes before
the class I'm not I mean I look at many
positions but I try to just bring my own
heuristics not computer analysis okay so
well then look at the position I see
that night and see if I was a problem my
advantage is the diagonal the bishop on
the long diagonal right and my central
majority and the extra point can be
agree first of all that any endgame as
long as I'm not losing the a6 pawn is
winning for black can we agree on that
yes okay so I am Not Afraid of trading
roast
am I not not really right so after Queen
c2 that was played I cannot play a5 a4
we see that this is not a bad move it's
actually the single it's controlling
them we were five or four right I can't
play five there's three pieces covering
a5 whereas I have only two defenders for
a5 is that right so one thing you can
think of as a plan is to put play Rock
adh first of all the last piece in the
game all of these pieces are playing the
last piece in the game and then the
bishop goes to a eight and now you
always have the move Queen c6 to be long
to build up the battery but that's not
the plan
the bishop runs a it opens this line for
the Queen that is why because once the
Queen is opened it can cover this to
square e six right are we good on that
it covers the score each six right are
we good and then I gradually go g6 and
a5 so I'm gonna add two more colors here
then my my majority starts rolling Luke
the eighth bishop AHG six f5 and I love
it all it takes to do that is to have
patience because for example you have to
be careful after g6 there is 94 there's
some some some tactics may pop up
because of f6 is squared so you want to
do those things you have to take your
time and not rush those who talked about
trading the Knights
it is okay to try the Knights because it
undermines the g2 squares it's trading
it one pair of nice is fine the problem
is the problem is what you do want the
knight on c5 later so if it's really
nice you have to make sure your majority
can steamroll can go forward further
forward okay so Queen c2 and here we see
black try to do that without pay unless
you do the little tactics and now here
white missed his chance after take take
you play for what about this Oh guys
don't miss the force don't miss free
three B's I always take the freebies I
know been fine goal has his rules but my
only have one rule really just is a very
difficult game to make rules for it just
take all the freebies take all the
freebies and be very stingy with your
pieces to give up
have you ever played for players chess
anybody I've ever played that you play
that so you know I then I kind of sleep
I play that sometimes and you think is
that the main thing about strategy there
there's no strategy so so bizarre that
is just there's no strategy it's just a
fun game don't trade pieces let them
kill each other and then play with extra
material right what is for all against
all if it's a team it's another story
but just and the thing be stingy with
your pieces and take all the freebies
take the freebies okay don't miss pork
so a for Bishop c4 Rock f3 rook 88 so
the black set of the bishop on c4 not
necessarily the best Square rook e1
low-key eight turkey three we take say
for not the best move either takes takes
now White's advantage has as blacks
advantage as substantially being
decreased but still there should be some
winning chances very good winning
chances here any questions by the way
okay the move Queen f6 was played and
then why play c4 why it shouldn't have
helped the King to the bishop to get
there
the main problem right now is this group
won't choose go aggressive for G to
school right that's the main problem
right and the Queen wants to come here
to f2 is that right how to stop that
Queen too
why should white do in this position
Quinn on a second-rank maybe a - then
you always can place it for maybe queen
- a - sorry maybe first okay okay three
you know doesn't Brooke is not generally
a good defended offensive piece so in my
opinion
Knights are known for being a good
defensive pieces and and the bishops not
but that more of the attacking pieces in
my opinion so Queens are good defensive
pieces they have good defensive able is
although not they cannot cover in front
of the in front of the king but they can
be on the side and cover from from
distance products are not the greatest
defenders in my opinion some better
players could could differ in opinion
but that's my experience
so yes Queen c2 what I would have think
of this more war
why should care about this defense so
why do I see four and now it only sends
the bishop to the right diagonal now
after this move black wood for example
here this was game over I guess black
didn't play this and then 93 okay that
stops a little bit this move this and
then Queen d4 I think again with t2 is
is quite dangerous here what I name is
not nice bad and after Queen c2 here
black pawns excellent move a5 now see if
I was unnecessary because c5 took away
undermined did not the Knights outpost
nice always need outpost I was finding
out your Knights outpost because they
can't just move around it takes time
they are very not turn another child
right so you have to be very careful
about that
what's that been you you have this broad
smile on your face so good alright
alright so and then after a five the
game is pretty much decided well good
game mr. Bishop to c4 we had fun with
this one
for the scheduled next game
so my name is Leo okay hi Leo 17 years
old and I have been playing chess okay
okay so it's his first win over against
clusters as a rated player in a
classical game well congratulations Leo
that's quite an achievement
right winning in a classical and he is
rated what 1700 so there's a 400 that's
a big upset and he won a classical game
so this is the fidelity tournament good
job - good good for Leo so let's have a
look at the game shall we
so since he won with black I just put
the port mm-hmm
d4 Knight f6 c4 c6 Knight c3 pitch of
your 7 kings in the end who plays Kings
in the end it's like somehow okay now
tell me guys what's the biggest setback
in King's India as a player who plays
King's in yet you don't have enough of
what you don't have enough space that's
the problem so the opening has one
fundamental problem that is lack of a
space so you have to be very creative
when you play d5 and white already
committed this move d5 not my favorite
move but he plays d5 and now black
played the move a file I think it's an
excellent choice why is it so I mean
everyone think for a minute maybe about
it
to push before that's one thing but
furthermore what else yes now I'm going
to use the square for my night either
this way or this way which would put
pressure on this pawn on e4 what's that
hi ginger Jima yeah I actually had a
chance to meet Simon he's a he's a very
very good very knowledgeable and very
good at what he does so so yeah this
this Knight wants to get to this course
c5 to put pressure on the Polynesia
white castles and that goes to a six I
actually prefer this just to keep the
bishop open not that it matters at this
moment but I'm I'm heading to him to
that square 91 actually it's it gave me
a lesson reminded me of something very
not very sort of painful so I in 2004 I
played this tournament in Moscow and
flute B group B open and that's where I
scored my last I am norm I'm my first
round game which is the only guy that's
not in database
I beat a I bit of an older international
master from Russia and that was a very
good game showing all these ideas and
plants from black side and I don't have
it so always make sure that you keep
your games even if the ones you'd lose
they are your trademark or signature in
the chess history and there's always
things to learn from them so I always
have this big regret there was there's
that one I want and there's another one
I won against Grandmaster Bo Logan in
the Greek league in Berlin defense and
not because of the game but the final
there is a very nice tactical there's
nice tactically both missed and he could
save it I missed the win and always save
your games always I learned it the hard
way
night c5f three now white wants to do to
the regular stuff so B 3 a 3 because a 3
right away is not good right a thrill I
play for and then I take this square so
now what your plan should be to play a 5
a 4 and push or or or you can activate
your knife by playing Knight h5 I think
actually this is better than what do
plate because the knight ones to land on
f4 so suppose if he goes here I can
connive for now not that I want to take
the bishop it's just active and if it
takes then this Bishop the bad Kings
Indian Bishop is now become a monster
you see that are we good men any
questions all right
so 937 is still it follows a plan that's
fine Bishop here and then f5 so the
reason I like the night on a four first
is that maybe there is something like
with 93 maybe with something with it
takes a five that takes under therefore
I need tonight wasn't h5 you could play
90s f4 here but now after after the
movie for not that black is worse but
just it's a regular position of the
Kings Indian where white ghost
white tries to go G 392 and try to place
this knight on a three building a block
it and then break through with G for a
different position
so Knight h5 kind of takes away
therefore idea we can check in the game
together here after Knight age five
Bishop b3 and then f5 although there's
always this problem Bishop takes e5
which is not the problem I think here
and if it takes of course we cannot take
with the picture because of g4 right
doesn't work like that so G takes a five
and then if f4 I take with a night and I
win that strong Bishop and now whites
dark scores are pretty undermined makes
sense after this this I can start my
attack like this maybe Bishop comes to
e5 f4 right a lot of weaker scores
around here are we good Ben are we good
a following been good so New York late
night ft 7 Bishop e3 f 5 a 3 here a 4 X
clam good job now this Knight has a home
now because there's no point can attack
it right and it's gonna sit here forever
the only setback is that now my rook is
painted this pawn but once the Queen
moves my arrow can move to and the Quai
worth more than the roof so as long as
I'm defending against a stronger
attacker you're not losing anything in
value does it make sense
you're rookies defend against the Queen
that's fine if the rook was defending
against a pawn or
pawns attack or a Queen's attack then
you were losing value in as an asset
right yoky is defending against one five
versus one but nice five versus nine so
that's fine 93 because be six now so
many may ask me what about if he takes
takes takes and not take that spawn a
shot you're talking about all these
things it's all gone what are you
talking about the direction I tell you
okay there's something cunning here
which I'm sure Leo considered what's the
kind of thing in this position everybody
two minutes nothing
two minutes why going bad
cunning
one more minute
then do we have any comments Rick says
Queen g'bye
okay or excess Queen g5 okay
abdel says queen g4 followed by Bishop
h3 I think he meant Queen g5 followed by
Bishop h6
what's the guy's thing in here what do
you guys think bishop f1
okay F therefore is the move you should
not play that's the move you should not
play because what why shouldn't you play
a four because you have what you have a
pair of bishop yep so it's a point
number one f4 is them no no move in this
position you you will not and you should
not and you must not play a four because
well if TB there's a bishop on a3 a4 is
good you win a temple and you start your
attack that's fine because you cannot
improve your luck dark square bishop but
the answer is do we have any more
comment pen not c5 yep okay the movies
bishop it's six now I want to I my ball
into this check and then landing on d4
which turned that bishop that kind of
timid was sitting on g7 turning into a
monster sitting on a three one thing I
like about this game is that gives me
the chance to show you a classical in
the King's in an attack game of course
our book of against Kasparov which I'm
gonna show right after if I finish this
one if we will have enough time but now
that Bishop sitting on e3 it's gonna be
a monster now for example let me make
make a few moves makes few smooth is
check and now now I play for the Bishop
is out of the chamber so if I go Knight
d5 like I mean I'm just making some
moves just to tell you show you how
strong this can be I'll go here
and now mate is coming if I go here
quintic says to check and nice man you
see that's all because of this guy
sitting on a three now we have a king on
J but he's the king of the board that
Bishop III is very very important it's
very very important so that because of
this move this move is not a this is not
a concern because black what cannot
prevent the Bishop III because if the
Queen moves you do not is hanging you
see that then then you lost upon then
you would have lost upon then you were
done to simply down the crown
yeah if the if the if the both dark
scores bishops are gone then f4 is
perfectly fine yeah
now f4 is absolutely a plan well in this
case being down upon and having a dark
square bishop and why not having a dark
square bishop then you really want
address the weakness of the dark squares
any any points been any comments then
you're here hello
he's not here he plays really good he
played a real good chess quincy to
Knight back to i think this is a move
that probably has some problems i think
he could just play much but what's that
here I was thinking maybe moves like 93
94 could be a possibility because if he
takes we take tonight goes takes here
that's fine now I can take on e4 and
play Queen g5 or Bishop e6 again right
now this not even cannot go back because
of this pawn on d4 so that was my
initial thought after I looked at this
position so Knight f6 I'm not sure now
because now if I take on c3
I mean okay I don't lose the pawn but I
don't know I'm not first time I was
thinking this he took I in this Bishop
d3 is a mistake in my opinion he takes
f5 is necessary and after and after G
takes f 5f for I'll lock it down because
if Bishop a5 I simply go for Bishop d3
well be my guest trading this Bishop
then I create a blockade on e4 and now
my bishop is bad on g7 the position is
balanced because of this pawn on e4 you
can take
and now you have to reroute your pieces
because you take this rook on p3 and you
put the pressure on this poem b2 but I
mean I can't just go here again the
position is balanced but this bishop is
not going to be anywhere important and
white has targets as well so are we good
it's a little bit complex as a concept
so White's move should have been he
takes a5 Bishop e3 is a huge tragic
mistake huge because now after a 40
share of two your move so usually in ink
in King's Indian white spawns roll up
with c5 before you know beginning this
but already black have created it kind
of like a like a like a block of bricks
right here right I mean if I he plays
Bishop d7 I cannot move my pawns if I
played before there is a there's on
Poisson here right and you can push up
your punch all the way here nothing
happens I check my QE g 5g for what
doesn't have enough defense over there
right make sense
and this move again another it's it's
too slow it's too slow we can offer and
now his attack is he was trying to run
away but his attack is too strong
actually I'm not sure about the merit of
this move but it's interesting I think I
think black can afford to play this one
and I like the way he he conducts his
attack he wins a temple every single
move
bring his acquaint of the game again I'm
not sure if he plays the people is best
but now yeah here's a threat knight
Knight to f4 and then wow he played this
move Bishop h3 Leo is the man he really
play well so she takes h3 rook rook here
King at g1 I'm not sure if actually now
is exactly winning but it's probably is
you see black white doesn't have any
defense you see all these guys right
here
whereas blacks pieces are all over here
doesn't make sense so white defends the
white is defending with two minor pieces
black is attacking with one and this
bishop can always join
so what attacks with five five pieces it
should prevail and it did well good game
from Lea do any comments or questions
from our okay
now I'm going to show you that King what
was that game I mention do you remember
the game it was who against who Auerbach
of against Kasparov
you don't have a mega eyes there's one
okay you need a mega 2019 but it works
because that game played in 90s so that
this one has it I don't have it here
all right
any questions before I show the game Ben
anyone has a question is everything
clear I think this was a very good game
right this was a very been nothing
so also burning - it's a record game
Oracle was known for his ability as a
blissful there he has become Moscow
Moscow Moscow
please champion several times so he was
back at the time he was a legendary
figure so they play this opening is
called a machine in King's Indian Castle
Bishop b3 b5 and the 92 nights and he
played c6 our conflict 22 know looking
at the right game 97 ID 5 city 5 city 5
years to the record a 6 so this is a
little bit different but it still we are
having the same pawn structure I'm
talking about this part so I'm just just
drawing something attack from this side
of the board's everything around here
so a6 is plying them of be 5 so 93 h5
Bishop d3 h b5 castle h4 92 9 h 5 a 4 B
4 9 82 895 and now here comes the moment
Bishop c4 and not yet maybe he took not
a good idea
now let's see what happens a dark scores
what did black do lets everyone I think
all right I think he played that yep 93
Bishop h6 Queen d3 you see he doesn't
care about this pawn on c5 the attack is
more important now
Queen d6 kind of stopping this he he
plays this was not only to defend the
pawn because taking there's always
couldn't be six but to blockade the pawn
and preparing him of Bishop d7 and then
Rukia f5 so his plan is like this
because that's where his attack is
Bishop b5 c4 I realize he plays on it
for the dark square so if if this
happens what happens guys if Bishop
takes c4
Quimby six check I guess is that what
happened here you should took okay play
first King g7 he this cannot be
prevented
he's this maneuver between b6 Bishop III
cannot be prevented this battery is very
important because I can play ricocheted
and then apply my g3 check will see how
it happens now this angie through check
is coming d6
bishop is okay just make sure the denies
that the bishops in the game Bishop c4
takes takes okay you grab the pawn but
not this I don't know if it was
necessary quince you just cook bit
should be through here are the reason is
that now the night the g3 check is not
as strong because Knight takes H takes
and nh3 you don't have the bishop here
to sacrifice on h3 that's why he picked
it up we don't have a sacrifice you
understand so if if I go here just take
stakes nh3 I don't have the means to
sacrifice the second time
so it takes rook takes Queen there Quinn
b5 and I he goes Bishop III octi 793
check takes takes takes and it goes
Queen is six and that's game over now he
has the means to sacrifice did he resign
your series I think let's look at it
again okay just from the moment so be
very cautious to give up that dark
square Bishop especially when they move
f3 has been committed and why it has
black has something like f5 or h5 or
something
be very cautious about giving up that
giving up that Bishop any questions or
comment then about this one
no so let's review it again okay just
one one more time we should take c5 he
takes e5 Knight c1 so one thing I said
about the want one thing I mentioned
about the Knights they are not that fast
but the bishop gets there very fast
right
23:26
Bishop if I probably suppose this was a
big mistake
white should have maybe move the pieces
first and sudden he goes c4 if it goes
Quincy for of course guys and there's
this there's Bishop e3 check
right and then this one
he probably continues with this although
I'm not sure after this the entire idea
works or not but should be fine like at
least has equality although I'm not sure
appreciate maybe is not a good love
maybe not g3 check should be committed
first let's let's ask let's ask the
computer maybe it's not it now it's a
zero or black is what is winning on my
god but that's the move you have to play
it says rookies first
it says King g7 first ah he's preparing
so c4 was a little bit but I suggest you
guys to go see for I don't know I feel
that c4 is the right move
- let's see for I don't know what white
isn't well of course
Quincy for Bishop c4 was a waste of time
Quincy for
by this step this very low I don't I
don't I don't trust this evaluation no
it should be should be good for black I
can't I can't accept this
okay I'll say okay it's going down
93 check
that's more accurate okay
sg3 loses right guys they made this
comment right are we good
so my g3 ashtec's G 320 seasick
a Quincy 6r we go for the mates
now this should be this should be really
good for black I don't I don't care what
what's his computers evaluation and it's
cropping also is going to zero black
with this Bishop on III and this file
open you cannot go wrong so what you
learn from the O's game
let's let's wrap it up let me close this
for okay now let's go to New Year's game
what was this what what did you learn in
King's Indian the dark score matters a
lot
it's dark square opening right
everything happens on dark score what
else you have to be very fast with your
attack white played very slowly and then
what happens is that blacks attack
started rolling and was impossible to
stop what was what else don't play a
three if your opponent has played a five
because after a for that night sits on
c5 forever you can't do much about it
Bishop should always be yes outside of
the paunchy yes yes
any questions Ben hmm
all good any questions guys anything
else so that's how you should you should
this should be like one tenth of the
analysis you have you would do for your
own games you have to be critical
detailed and spend a lot of time
learning from your games and that's how
you can get better and when you learn
something don't say oh I lost that game
I won't change my opening don't do that
learn and replayed
all right I don't have much more to say
I don't think we have time for one more
game then we keep it a short break and
we continue with romantic games and
games basically all right well thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]